George Santos comes clean and admits he
was a queen embattled New York GOP
Congressman George Santos finally
admitted to Once Upon a Time dressing in
drag yep he actually admitted to
something that immediately disqualifies
him from politics
last week a former friend alleged they
dressed and dragged together when Santos
was a teenager living in Brazil wow
teens in Brazil grow up fast
I didn't start dressing in drag until I
had to co-host outnumbered
by the way
yeah it's me my my outnumbered name is
Ashley van perrywinkle
I can talk about any topic so call me
anyway this weekend reporters caught up
with Santos at the airport before he
could pre-board with a fake neck injury
who hasn't but I wonder if he was young
and had fun at a festival and whether we
should sue him for having a life young
and I had fun at a festival sue me for
having a life
Amen brother or sister or whatever
so Santos did dress in drag nothing to
be ashamed of you know and like lying
about where your mother was on 9 11. I
mean for a guy with a 3.89 GPA that's
pretty stupid
Sienna College poll shows that 71
percent of New York suburbanites believe
he should resign compared to 50 who said
no and he should stay while the
remaining 14 would like him to offer
some tips on how to apply eyeliner
but this means that despite his
unpopularity he's still slightly more
popular than the rest of Congress
for more insight joining me live from
Washington
Republican Congressman George Santos
thank you
[Applause]
thanks for taking the time to speak with
us George uh questions on everybody's
mind are you planning on resigning
no I'm not going to resign Greg and I'm
not gonna maybe the media should resign
for not finding out I'm a liar until
after I was elected I mean a lot of
people want you to resign Greg Brian
Williams Brian stelter Brian kill me but
they're the disgusting Liars not not us
yo you're right they did you know what
about the allegations though are you
worried the feds are going to be coming
for you
yes I'm worried the feds are coming I've
got a gas stove or maybe I stole money
from a veteran's dog Greg but the fact
I'm worried about is the money that the
government is stealing from veterans
through taxes oh good point so how did
you come up with your uh drag name
Katara rivachi Greg I can come up with
fake names all day George Santos Anthony
kabler I don't know Ainsley Earhart
that's the easy part Greg the
hardpotters are remembering what name
you gave them and what your fake mother
was doing on September 11th
finally what would you tell your former
friend who said you couldn't cut it as a
professional drag queen was or was he a
catty
yes he was a catty I would tell
her that a lot of people back then said
that my lip syncing in 2005 was better
than Beyonce's lip sync during Obama's
Inauguration in 2009 even though the
timeline doesn't really add up
well thank you Congressman we'll be uh
we'll check back in with you later and
please you're always welcome on the show
Congressman George Santos
Rick I don't know if you've been
following this guy at all yeah it is a
pile of Lies but how is he any worse
than any politician I at least I know
what he is this is why I never wanted to
cover politics this is why I didn't want
to work at the White House or work in DC
because I didn't want anything to do
with that nonsense yeah yeah this guy is
the epitome of why the whole system is
screwed up and why he's why is he still
there yeah when he lied about everything
and people elected him thinking he was
one thing and then find out he's
something completely different yeah and
all the stuff that he told him on the
campaign Trail turned out to be BS I'm
shocked that they haven't done more to
kick him out of Congress already I
wonder if they're waiting to find
somebody but but also it might have been
clever on the Dems to hold all this
stuff right cats so then he got elected
and he could now we're stuck with them
what do you think cat answer me about
what
I mean like I yeah I think you should
resign but I think that I'm like trying
to think of somebody in the government
that I don't want to resign exactly I
don't know it's like I find him because
he's such a liar to be the most
transparent politician ever because we
know he's a liar oh my God
[Laughter]
I said I want them all to resign not
that I want just him not to uh but also
like we are we already knew I like he
admit he's not I don't think he gets to
say he admits it because he was still
denying it when there was a photo of
himself yes and I said that all along
that he did drag but he wasn't a queen
because I wish we could get a picture up
there of him in it like he didn't even
attempt to do a contour it looks stupid
it was bad I just kept thinking the guy
who was playing he was playing Santos
that wasn't really him right
I kept thinking his face must hurt
holding that pose for that his friend's
makeup is way better better he was not
good at it RuPaul would see that I don't
know if he'd laugh or cry but he'd
definitely throw up I'm gonna say Tyrus
I'm man enough masculine enough
comfortable in my own skin to say that
George Santos was a great looking drag
queen no hey it's your party man dancing
he looks like Gretchen Whitmer here I'm
going to defend I'm gonna
that's late in the night in Brazil
um oh I've been there I would I'm gonna
I'm gonna take her for George a little
bit you know thank you because
71 percent said he needed to go right
yeah 71. so what's his favorabilities
like right around 29 right so he's like
six back from the president exactly
because the president was like 36 right
so he's in good company that's what I'm
saying like well they all want you to
leave well a president's only eight
points ahead of me I mean that's
something saying something and
transparent by evidence and force is not
the same as transparent yeah he just got
busted and we all see through the veil
so to speak yeah sounds like uh someone
else we know President Biden yeah
exactly he's cooperating yeah he's been
holding this up for 20 years now he's
cooperating yeah when you caught by the
police yeah and they're like yeah um
so that's all he's doing he's
cooperating right every serial killer
ever caught I'm cooperating the bottom
line is like let's be honest the
Democrats had him in that one of those
boxes breaking case of emergency right
so sudden when they found the third
stash right and when they found the
secret documents in the garage next to
the Corvette break the Santos glass now
get this story out there Ram it through
I mean there's no way we this should be
this big of a story a congressman lied
yeah oh but he's no longer a drag denier
which is the biggest thing because yeah
we talked about that before being a drag
denier apparently is the only thing he
will not tolerate exactly exactly now
he's now he's um what do you call a drag
he's an advisor what do you call the
what do you call the fat people the body
positive he's correct positive oh he's
drag positive
it sounds really weird you put the in
front of fat people
like there's just one little of the fat
people
I'm glad you brought that up okay what
the fat family lived next door to me
p-h-a-t the fat family lives next door
oh that's what you were talking about
yeah how do you people feel now ah
those facts
will you try that home no babe I meant
p-h-a-t I'm in pretty hot and tempting
not fat like you thought
wait is that what it stands for pretty
hot and tempting that's what came out of
my mind at the moment yes
because I felt like I just learned
something new Cyrus that was brilliant
quick on my feet all right we got to get
out of this filthy segment yeah I'm
gonna need to bathe afterwards my
collar's all screwed up hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else